we've all suffered focusing on the
urgent at the expense of the important
um dwight eisenhower used to talk about
this he called them
they've been since called the eisenhower
principles where you you organize
basically all the things you have to do
based on what's urgent what's important
the things you do first are the
important urgent things then you do the
important non-urgent things
then you get to uh
urgent and unimportant than unimportant
and unurgent um and the opportunities
what can you delegate
um uh
jack daley the famous sales coach says
you know if you don't have an assistant
you are one um basically uh what it
means is we need help like everybody
needs help and it has nothing to do with
being an assistant it means it means
that there are things that we can
actually give away that we don't think
we can or we there's things that we
don't actually have to do um if you're
like me i focus on the urgent stuff as a
means of procrastination
you know because i can get that stuff
done and i know i can do it and and the
whole idea is like i'm just going to do
it because i can do it better
yes but you're driving yourself crazy
and you're going to hurt your business
um there may be a short-term dip like
one of the mistakes that that she made
was how can i focus on everything and
make this transition without losing
anything well if you're going to start
to delegate and teach somebody something
there may be a short term dip in
in performance um
but that's only while there is a
learning curve and so ultimately you
have to accept that you there's no such
thing as teaching somebody and
maintaining steep growth and you cannot
go back to the i'll just do it myself
and
you have to make a decision what are the
things that i have to work on only i can
work on and what are things that i can
delegate
automate ask for help outsource
and the more you can do that the more
you learn to ask for help the more you
start working
up and out versus down and in
one of the things that i found
helpful as well is to think of myself as
my own employee right so i have two hats
i have i'm leader hat and i've got doer
hat right and so i'll make decisions as
to like okay i'm in leader mode now i'm
going to focus on up and out i'm going
to focus on networking i'm going to
focus on strategy and i accept that
doing will have to come a little later
and then i put on my doer hat so i sort
of like force myself to recognize that
i'm i'm focusing too much on urgent at
the expense of importance so i remember
that i have two hats that i have to wear
both
small business owners own small
businesses entrepreneurs solve problems
they're entrepreneurs and big companies
they're entrepreneurially minded right
they're problem solvers they're they're
a little more maverick than than
everyone else there are people who have
small businesses who are not
entrepreneurs they just run
small
healthy lifestyle businesses perfectly
fine but it's they sort of go through
the motions and so i think there's a
couple questions you know which is if
somebody wants to
start their own business
um
i think they have to be brutally honest
with themselves as the reasons why
because
an entrepreneurial venture
is balanced just like having a job is
balanced like when you have a
corporate job you work for an
established company you know
your highs are not that high but your
lows are not that low
it's balanced right like a win is
exciting but a loss you know it's it's
over here when you do your own thing the
highs are amazing and the lows are
excruciating right it's balanced and so
everybody wants this but not everybody
has the the gut for this and so i think
somebody has to recognize that it's the
thrill of the journey
um because
you may not make more money than you
used to make and so the question is is
it worth it and you may be working more
hours than you used to for the same
amount of money so the question is why
are you doing this you have to be
crystal clear why you're doing this and
if you are clear on why you're doing it
and the reasons are compelling meaning
you're running two something not away
from something
um then quite frankly the risk
seems to just go down you start to feel
like
i have to do this i i have to give it a
try
you know and we're very lucky that we
live in the united states because in the
united states we love the try you know
if you if you live somewhere else you
know in europe for example
people look down on failure and so
people are more risk averse here if you
try something and it doesn't work out
we're like
freaking great you know
we love that um
and i think when you set out make sure
you know who you know
who you're going to ask for help
you know because you cannot do it alone
um no one of us is strong enough or
smart enough to to build a business by
ourselves and i don't mean we have to
hire people means we need support we
need emotional support we need advice we
need people to lean on we need people
who've done it before it doesn't mean we
follow all the advice but but we have to
be really good at saying i don't know
and i need help
um
and if you if you have that nagging
curiosity it's it's kind of like you
know you you saw something in a store
and you're still thinking about it maybe
you should just go back and buy it it's
the same thing like if you're still
thinking about it but you're doing it
for the right reasons you're not doing
it because i hate my boss i'm just going
to start my own business but you're
doing it because you believe you have a
better mouse trap because there's a
better way of doing this that there's a
problem you can solve that hasn't been
solved or you just believe you can you
can do it in a way that nobody else
wants to do it you're frustrated then
then it's the greatest most exciting
scary wonderful awful fantastic
brilliant thing you'll ever do all at
the same time yeah